unfortunately it seems no amount of
money will entice the proudly ignorant
socialist Alexandria Ocasio Cortez to
publicly debate any of her terrible
policy proposals but if that cash is
burning a hole in your wallet
don't worry disgraced FBI agent and
all-around twerp
Peter struck is perfectly willing to
take it on his GoFundMe as the left
ramps up censorship of conservatives we
will explain the current price of free
speech it ain't free baby
then George Gilder steps by to discuss
the death of Google and the rise of
blockchain finally you'll be shocked to
hear this one the mainstream media think
that President Trump is stupid can you
believe it
we'll analyse the latest accusation in
light of all the others I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
Oh
[Music]
I couldn't believe it when I when I read
that that they think they the media they
think Trump is stupid shocking it's
shocking we'll get down there there's
also we have a little this day in
America segment or the state of minutes
two of my segments this is America
segment where we'll talk about what a
cool guy Chris Pratt is before all that
let's make a little money honey how
about that let's talk about Dollar Shave
Club look at my cheeks look at how
smooth they are so supple so nice
that's because of Dollar Shave Club
actually that's because of - Dollar
Shave products so you know I love their
Dollar Shave product the executive razor
though all of the blades it is the best
razor I've ever used in my life you
should for sure get it the other reason
is sometimes you know I'll go on Fox and
Friends sometimes early in the morning
and I'll come back and I'll need to take
my makeup off and I don't have anything
to do that other than my one wipe
Charlies so let me tell you those one
wipe Charlies can cover you
top to bottom they feel just as good on
your face as they do as your portable
b-day you're sure you you should try all
of their products they're all really
really good they've got the body
cleanser amber lavender body cleanser
they've got this daily essential starter
kit which is the one that you should for
sure check out right now you can get an
amazing deal with any one of the starter
sets daily essentials is great because
it comes with the body cleanser you
can't go wrong with any of them go to
dollarshaveclub.com slash cough fa ce
o-- v f EF e to pick your DSC starter
set for just five dollars that is just
five dollars for the best razor you've
ever used in your life plus all that
other stuff it is practically free you
should go get it after your starter set
products ship at the regular price that
is dollarshaveclub.com slash cough FAC o
VF EF e go do it don't say I never did
nothing for you get the best razor
you've ever used dollarshaveclub.com
slash cough fa co v fe fe okay lot to
get to today i want to start out
basically by i'm just gonna be honest
with you I'm just gonna lay this on the
table I want someone to pay me $10,000
to debate them why what I didn't note it
all I'm on Twitter all the time
everybody's offering ten thousand twenty
thousand a hundred thousand dollars to
debate them on how terrible socialism is
I'll settle for a hundred bucks you know
that Ben doesn't pay me you know that
I'm here in this broom closet wasting
away over here I was living in a
dumpster in an alternate universe you
some money honey the way this all began
if you're a little confused on who's
offering who money for what this began
because Alexandria Casio Cortez said
that the Republicans are afraid to
debate her Alexandria Casio Cortez Wow
Wacka will talk to a nobel-prize Michael
Wacha Wacha
she said that there Republicans are
afraid to debate her so Bennett says I
will debate you I in fact I will donate
$10,000 to your campaign to debate you
on the merits of socialism so she didn't
want to do that obviously she said it
was cat calling I don't I don't know how
she came up with this one she said that
accepting a debate challenge say
challenging someone to a bed accepting
debate challenge
he's cat calling why did she say that
I'll allow Alexandria to explain in her
own words I am NOT the expert
geopolitics on this issue hmm it makes a
lot of sense she's not the expert she
didn't know she that's fair enough so
she says she's not gonna do it
Alexandria Cassio Cortes Jenny from
Yorktown Heights says I'm not going to
take this debate so then they turn it up
a notch she pulled the gender card so
then Candice Owen says I'll give you 20
grand and I think Charlie Kirk said
we'll give you a hundred grand and then
I don't know if the number is at like a
hundred billion dollars right now or
something but either way she's not going
to do it why won't she why won't she do
it one of the responses that the
Democrats have all lined up on is she's
just running this one congressional race
she only has to debate her opponent she
only has to debate her opponent she
doesn't need to debate random people
like for instance the guy with the
biggest conservative talk show in the
country you know as you don't need to do
that right you don't need to do that she
if she had just stuck to her race then
she wouldn't have to but she has
positioned herself as the future of the
Democratic Party the head of the DNC Tom
Perez says that Alexandria Ocasio Cortes
is the future of the Democrat Party she
is going all around the country she's
stumping for candidates in Michigan
she's raising money in California she
stumped for that one candidate she went
out and gave her introduction then
forgot to introduce the candidate she
was endorsing because it's all about her
she's the future of the party she's
positioned herself this way if you're
going to be the future of the party
then you have to debate people then you
have to be out there in the public arena
and talk to people outside of New York's
14th congressional district which is
very Rd is New York's 14th congressional
district is something like 90% Democrat
it's a D+ 21 district I think or D plus
29 district it is solidly Democrat so
she's got to think outside of here if if
she wants to or if she wants to be the
head of that party but she isn't going
to do that this gets to part of the
Democrats problem with free speech right
now because she's made herself this
superstore if she wants to be the
superstore why not why not engage in the
free exchange of ideas what what is
stopping her I get practically what's
stopping her she doesn't know anything
and she sounds very foolish every time
she goes on TV I see the practical
reason but then maybe she shouldn't be
the head of the party she won't she will
not take the money no matter how high
the numbers go up she won't take the
money meanwhile money is pouring in to
Peter struck Peter struck you'll
remember that name he's the guy who
texted his girlfriend the girl he was
having an affair with his colleague and
said I'm gonna stop Trump from becoming
president don't worry he'll never become
president as he's investigating
President Trump as he's working in the
FBI during the 2016 election got fired
from the mulher a campaign if you don't
remember him here is Peter struck
looking like a demon before before trey
gowdy in congress your testimony is Bob
Muller did not kick you off because of
the content of your text he kicked you
all because of some appearance that he
was worried about my testimony what you
asked and what I responded to was that
he kicked me off because of my bias I'm
stating to you it is not my
understanding that he kicked me off
because of any bias that it was done
based on the appearance if you want to
represent what she said accurately I'm
happy to answer that question but I
don't appreciate what was originally
said being changed I don't give a damn
what you appreciate agent struck I don't
appreciate having an FBI agent with an
unprecedented level of animus working on
two major investigations during 2016 Oh
trey Gowdy why are you going away why
are you leaving that that's struck he
comes off as smug he had this weird sort
of demonic smile look on his face during
his testimony but how smug this is a guy
the audacity of
his GoFundMe campaign is jaw-dropping
this is a guy who has worked his entire
life on the public dole right he's
worked a taxpayer expense his entire
life then he was caught being corrupt
he's caught cheating on his wife with a
co-worker promising her that he's going
to use the power of the state the
coercive power of the state to undermine
a democratic election to undermine a
presidential election to subvert that
election and prevent Donald Trump from
becoming president he then just waits he
just sits around he says I'm not gonna
resign I'm not gonna quit finally they
were able to push this guy out of the
bureaucracy what's the first thing he
does he puts his hand out again and says
give me more money I need more money
give me more of your money and the
American people really just lefties they
give him more money they we must be so
rich right now because of the Trump
economy that money is literally burning
a hole in people's pockets that they're
gonna give it to this schmuck
it is unfathomable he puts up his his
GoFundMe campaign and I believe the
limit was $150 at $150,000 that's what
he wanted he has now had to up that
limit twice because people keep pouring
money in do you know how much this guy
has raised $300,000 because he got fired
for being terrible at his job and
corrupt and trying to subvert democratic
processes he's raised three hundred
thousand dollars that's what the left
has rewarded him with three hundred
thousand dollars that by the way isn't
nearly three hundred dollars per minute
if you if you factor in all of the
waking hours that we have this guy's
making about three hundred bucks per
minute they've raised it twice here's
what the GoFundMe campaign says this is
what's written on what Peter struck a
man who has spent his entire life
working to help keep us and our nation's
safe has been fired he needs your help
for the last year Pete his work and his
character have been the target of highly
politicized attacks including frequent
slanderous statements from President
Trump who actively and apparently
successfully pressured FBI officials to
fire Pete no no he wasn't the target of
politicized attacks he is the
politicized attack he politicized the
FBI to attack a presidential election in
to attack president Trump
what he did it's unbelievable I told you
yesterday was the projection day for the
Democratic Party it was the I know you
are but what am i day they constantly
project what they're doing on to their
opponents the the go fund me goes on
Peter struck is a proud husband and
father and I end the show there I how am
I supposed to make fun of that Peter
struck the only reason we know this
guy's name is because he was cheating on
his wife with a co-worker with he wasn't
even just cheating on his wife with
Sally from the diner he was actually
cheating on his wife so violating their
their marriage and violating the bonds
of his with himself and his employer who
is the American people he's working for
the American people he's working in the
government at an executive agency a law
enforcement agency that demands
integrity and he's cheating on his wife
with his coworker he's a proud husband
and father are you kidding me he goes on
a veteran of the US Army and
counterintelligence special agent who
spent more than two decades in a job he
loved at the FBI yeah I bet you loved
the job I bet you loved the job I bet
you loved feeling empowered to subvert
presidential elections I bet you loved
apparently having little dalliance 'as
with your coworkers I bet you loved that
feeling like you controlled the power of
the state to stop the American people
from selecting the president that they
want I'm sure you loved it tough noogies
buddy it goes on but last week in a
decision apparently driven by political
pressure a senior FBI official chose to
fire Pete the the reason you were fired
is because you were horrible at your job
and you violated the trust of the
American people the shocking story here
is not that that Peter struck was fired
the shocking story is that he was
allowed to keep his job as long as he
did which just shows you the inertia of
the federal bureaucracy it shows you why
we have to slash the power and size and
scope of the federal bureaucracy but he
kept his job anyway unbelievable
$300,000 this guy gets the left now is
pouring money giving money to a
lecherous criminal bureaucrat that's
where they think the money should go
where else could this money go I don't
know like any charity could go there why
don't they give it they're always
whining about how
federal government doesn't have enough
money why don't they give their money to
the federal government no they're giving
it to this lecherous creep this little
twerp who lives his whole life on the
taxpayer on taxpayer handouts while
simultaneously violating the public
trust and then he demands more money
puts his hand out no shame whatsoever no
show could you imagine the shame you get
fired for your job for violating the
public trust and cheating on your wife
and you trying to subvert a presidential
election and then the first instinct is
gimme gimme gimme I can't support myself
gimme gimme gimme
so pathetic what a little twerp and
they're giving money to that guy the
left is giving money to that guy and
it's this all ties in with the debates
this all ties in with with free speech
because the the left right now it feels
an utter disdain for the essence of this
country it feels a disdain for freedom
for the freedom that the United States
represents and for the country and for
the countrymen why do they like Peter
struck because Peter struck tried to use
the power of the state in his own words
he boasts about it in his own words
using the power of the state to stop
Americans from electing the president
they want and the left doesn't like
freedom doesn't like the country doesn't
like the American country they applaud
people when they protest the flag itself
the symbol of the country and they don't
like their countrymen they slander them
with all sorts of nonsense constantly
calling them Nazis and white
supremacists anybody who's to the left
of Vladimir Lenin is a Nazi all of a
sudden Rove white supremacists or
something that's why they like him
because Peter struck apposed freedom he
opposed democratic order he opposed his
country in his countrymen that's why
they like it you see that same thing
with the debate they won't debate the
Left will not debate we're offering them
$100,000 they won't debate why they
don't want to engage with us they can't
defend their point of view they need
censorship it's all about shut down
censorship back off block you on Twitter
give money to the lecherous creep who
tries to subvert democracy it's all
about that I was on Fox and Friends so
at this weekend and we were talking
about this these teachers in Boston or
in a Massachusetts suburb who openly
admitted that they were going to become
liberal
propagandists they were going to
disregard objectivity in their teaching
that they were going to brainwash their
students there they're admitting this in
a in a meeting that has been uncovered
we were discussing this on Fox & Friends
and and Edie Henry and Abby Huntsman
repeated multiple times if you're one of
these teachers and you want to come on
and have your voice heard come on we'll
have you on come on come on the show
we'll have you on but you don't see that
from the left you don't see the left
saying come on and we'll talk it's only
the right that does that it's only right
leaning networks like Fox like us I've
many Democrats have I invited on this
show every day I try to win by Democrats
on this show two people have taken me up
on that one of whom is Tom Arnold and I
was great I had a good time doing that
we're the right is constantly inviting
people in constantly inviting people to
talk the left will not do that the left
never has an actual Republican on their
networks who was the last Republican to
actually go on CNN yeah actually I know
they had Anna Navarro on all the time
someone who took to my knowledge has
never once actually advanced the
Republican or conservative cause but
she's they call her a Republican
strategist because she plays one on CNN
you know Anna Navarro who all of these
people who's the oh that one who's so
awful in the what Jennifer Rubin they
pretend that Jennifer Rubin is a
lifelong lefty they pretend that she's a
Republican or a conservative we don't
have people on and now you're seeing big
tech do this you know look you saw that
they banned Alex Jones from YouTube and
Facebook now they banned Gavin McGinnis
from Twitter who knows who's next
they're getting a progressively more
mainstream Eve even Noam Chomsky thinks
this is bad no less a lefty than Noam
Chomsky thinks this is a terrible thing
and opposes the censorship of people
like Alex Jones if you aren't familiar
with Noam Chomsky here's it here's an
example of a bygone day of your when the
left was willing to engage in discourse
here is Noam Chomsky on Bill Buckley's
firing line
I've rejoice in your disposition to
argue the Vietnam question especially
when I recognize what an act of
self-control this must involve it does
sure it really does I mean I think
there's a kind of issue sometimes I lose
my temper maybe not
because as you would have smashing the
gun you said you say in your reason for
not losing you say the war is simply an
obscenity a depraved act by weak and
miserable men including all of us
including myself including every that's
the next sentence citizens so you heard
that the Vietnam War is a weak and
miserable act but undertaken by depraved
men this is not a moderate person this
is not this is a far left person Noam
Chomsky but even he is saying this
tendency of the left to just censor to
refuse to engage to refuse to debate
he's on Bill Buckley show Buckley is
actually making a joke about his debate
with gore Vidal on television where he
said if you don't record crypto Nazi or
I'll smash you in your damn face and
don't stay plastered you queer you know
it goes on and on he's making a joke
about this and they're laughing about
this and engaging in an exchange of
ideas this no longer happens the right
now a big tech is escalating its attacks
big tech is controlled by the left the
people who run these companies are left
wingers they're under immense pressure
from the left right now because the left
blames big tech for the 2016 Trump
victory they blame Facebook for allowing
conservative news so-called fake news to
pervade the platform they blame Twitter
for the Russian BOTS everything's a
Russian but I'm a Russian bot and they
are constantly blaming big tech they're
under pressure and they're caving there
they're censoring people right now this
is bad and I get really sick and tired
of even conservatives who say well big
tech they can do whatever they want it's
not a big deal they can do whatever they
want the First Amendment doesn't they
have the they have their rights to
speech it's the First Amendment that's
fine yes
nobody duh nobody disagrees with you
that a company can do what it wants to
do although one has to remember if
you're a plaid
you're a publisher there are certain
rules that go along with that but yeah
nobody is saying that they can't do it
we're saying they shouldn't do it we're
saying it creates a bad culture it's a
bad society it's not in keeping with
American premises it's not in keeping
with American ideals to censor people
with whom you disagree sure it's not an
issue of the First Amendment perhaps but
it is an issue of the cultural products
that go with the First Amendment of the
American ethos it is an issue of that
big government is very bad censorship by
big government is bad but big
corporation isn't that much better
because it's a little bit better because
it has usually less of a monopoly but
that's you know the corporate culture in
America does define our culture in so
many ways when a CEO gets run out of
town on a rail because he's contravened
the the latest leftist orthodoxy the the
leftist orthodoxy du jour that's not
that's not good that's not something we
should celebrate say oh well it's
freedom they know it's okay no that's
okay they can do it of course they can
do it nobody's disagreeing what we're
saying should they do it there's a
thought that stops thought and that's
the only thought that ought to be
stopped censorship is bad censorship is
bad per se especially in America and
when corporations do it we shouldn't
just shut down the conversation and say
well they can they can hey they can
right yeah sure but should they should
we hold them accountable and say no
don't censor people don't especially
when you've got all outsized power
especially when you've got the data of
all Americans especially if you know
where Americans are at all times
everywhere and especially when you work
with the government when you are
constantly in contact with the
government all of these big tech firms
are fortunately there's some hope in
this there are some writers and
economists and technologists who are
offering hope one of those is George
Gilder George Gilder is an American
investor economist and author of the
international bestseller wealth and
poverty which made the case in the early
1980s for supply-side economics and
capitalism he was the most often quoted
living author by President Ronald Reagan
and he now predicts the eventual if not
imminent fall of Google and big tech
companies in his new book life after
Google the fall of big data and the rise
of the block
economy i sat down with George Gilder a
few days ago to discuss why I shouldn't
worry too much about Google and why
should buy a lot of Bitcoin without
further ado here is mister gilder mister
gilder thank you so much for being here
right to be there so the book is life
after Google the fall of Big Data the
rise of the blockchain economy you know
my show personally has been censored by
Google by YouTube I know a lot of people
now especially conservatives but across
the political spectrum have big gripes
with big technology big data give us
hope this is a welcome message that
there will be a life after Google but
why is there gonna be a life after
Google why is Google and big tech gonna
fall and what comes next because the
Internet architecture that that Google
and all the big internet leviathans
managed has reached the end of the line
it doesn't supply security it doesn't
supply privacy it can't sustain
factuality
it really can't ultimately sustain
transactions because transactions are
necessarily dependent on security so
Google's response is to give everything
for free and but because who wants to
steal free stuff but ultimately on this
aggregate and advertised strategy that
they're pursuing reaches a dead end
you are if you're giving away stuff for
free is your dominant model you you're
the internet fills up with unwanted
value subtracted minuses called
ads and the whole system breaks into
separate walled gardens of Muller's of
Iran have a walled garden government of
China which makes perfect sense that too
nerds and Google can have their walled
garden and and Mark Zuckerberg had his
this segmented Internet has reached the
end of the line as the essence of it and
it's just like IBM you know we everyone
thought IBM was the dominant Empire of
information technology thirty years ago
and the government mobilized regulate it
and Sue it just at the point that it
that it began to subside into the
background of our lives of course and
you it's it's funny the IBM example is
great because I wonder even if a lot of
Millennials watching this show remember
how dominant IBM was and then it began
to subside and now it seems virtually
impossible to think of a world after the
dominance of these big tech companies in
your book you refer to these Silicon
Valley types the heads of Google and
Facebook as neo-marxists they have a
neo-marxist view of themselves and of
the world I think a lot of conservatives
suspect that on a gut level but what do
you mean by that well the essence of
Marxism was Marx's belief that the
Industrial Revolution of the 19th
century was the final human attainment
it it provided productivity beyond any
possible needs and in the future the
only issue would be how to distribute
existing wealth rather than how to
create new wealth Google and and itself
today believe that they're machine
learning their artificial intelligence
their robotics their algorithms
represent the ultimate human attainment
it's their error is even grander than
Marx's because Marx didn't imagine that
the steam engine could usurp the human
mind but Brennan cage imagined that
their machine intelligence can usurp and
transcend human minds and a grand
singularity and you believe that this is
foolishness as it was foolishness back
then because we hear so much that in the
future and then in the not-too-distant
future people aren't really going to
have to work there's going to be so much
abundance from this techno utopia that
you people will just don't just get a
handout I don't know you can write
poetry or something like that you won't
really have a work and and you're
writing speaks sort of uniquely to the
dignity of the human person to the
dignity of the individual this sounds
like very good news for especially for
conservatives but for all of us oh why
is it that we don't have to fear the
SuperDuper AI singularity running
wreaking havoc and and you know
surpassing all of human achievement and
intelligence it's just so it's just is
delusional it's the belief a vast
exaggeration of the significance of your
own the technology of your own time of
your own inventions their computers
these big data centers next giant rivers
and glaciers around the world that
Google's building have nothing to do
with human intelligence they have to do
with processing huge amounts of data
faster than it's ever been processed
before in human history and that that
data processing that they call machine
intelligence is in fact totally dumb it
is utterly dependent on human brains at
every point of its development and
deployment and definition and an
application and to the extent that it
increases human productivity it will
result in more jobs and better jobs and
safer jobs and work
creative jobs than ever before there's
no evidence whatsoever that technology
on net has ever destroyed a job and like
and that the failure to deploy
technology Luddite ISM and and
environmental overreach can all destroy
jobs but technology cannot and it not
only can it not destroy a job but it
can't be a conscious mind of course and
it's interesting that you bring up the
Luddites because I think a lot of the
times the political left wants to paint
conservatives that we're the Luddites
we're resisting change we're the ones
who won't adopt new things meanwhile the
it is the left that's resurrecting you
know stale 19th century political
ideology running on socialism in this
election
it's the left which is relying on these
old centralized
technologies that seem to be if your if
your thesis is right seem to be heading
the way of the dodo the subtitle of the
book is the fall of Big Data and the
rise of the blockchain economy what does
that mean does that mean we have to all
go out and invest in Bitcoin right now
what is the the future of the blockchain
economy and what does it mean for for
politics and for politics as well as
technology the let the black chain is a
new architecture for security on the
internet that rip rip it starts as a new
form of money
and unlike cash which affords the
anonymity but doesn't give you a record
of your transactions this blockchain
economy provides you with anonymity you
don't have to expose yourself on the
screen in order to get a conductive
transaction on the Internet but at the
same time if some
we prosecutor comes after you and claims
that you're avoiding taxes or concealing
transactions or you can document
unimpeachably your your own behavior so
it combines anonymity with attestation
in a unique way in a major advance for
money
it also redistributes power today of
these walled garden these leviathans
segmented internet with porous security
allows all the money and power to be
sucked up to the top where the only
security is supplied the new technology
the BOK blockchain is peer-to-peer and
and universal and a boy and put security
in your own device and in your own hands
with your own content which you can
transact with others across the internet
without disclosing all your own personal
data well you keep using that word that
that very few people on the internet for
for recent memory have used which is
security and now obviously big tech has
gotten into a lot of trouble for this
they're being hauled before Congress
because they've been so loose with their
security there have been so many
invasions there has been so much theft
of data why is that how is it that these
guys Google Facebook that they seemingly
ignored security for so long and and how
is it that blockchain brings that
security back well they they ignore
security because because they were
giving away all their stuff for free
they thought they'd discovered the
magical strategy to move beyond
capitalism to this new eschaton as Bill
Buckley would have called it yeah
eminent izing the eschaton is that right
imagining that your own era represents
the
final things the final human solution
and and this is this is the Marxist
vision and it's the Google vision and
it's being transcended by the blockchain
which keeps your own data with you and
allows you to use it as you choose
across the internet rather than
depending on on Facebook and Google and
it all to tell you who you are and
whether you're permitted to proceed
further with any action across the net
well you I believe I read somewhere that
you were the most cited living author by
President Ronald Reagan he cited you the
most and Ronald Reagan was fond of
saying that the government big enough to
give you everything you want is big
enough to take away everything you have
and it seems that the same principle
applies to big technology companies
we're all so afraid of think of Google
and Facebook because they have all of
our stuff there they're playing
loosey-goosey with it and they can they
can really manipulate it and to say
nothing of censoring people and
targeting up people for unpopular
political points of view so this is a
really a breath of fresh hope and it's
so well written that it's really
understandable I do not I am somewhat of
a Luddite in that I really don't
understand technology and the book is
really clearly written it is a must-read
life after Google the fall of Big Data
and the rise of the blockchain economy
the author George Gilder mister gilder
thank you so much for being here
delighted and thank you for having me
all right what a cool guy most quoted it
writer by President Ronald Reagan most
quoted living writer that's not bad
okay I've gotta say goodbye if you're on
Facebook and YouTube go to daily
wire.com if you're already there thank
you very much you helped keep khofifah
in my cup we have a ton more to talk
about I have to talk about the shocking
breaking news story that the mainstream
media think that Donald Trump is stupid
we'll analyze that will analyze the Paul
Manafort case what's going on with that
and the latest allegations against DNC
deputy chairman Keith
listen nobody else is covering it so I
suppose we should you know it's almost
time for our next episode of the
conversation on Tuesday August 21st at
5:30 Eastern 2:30 Pacific i michael
knowles the one and only your guide
through all of this political craziness
will answer your questions moderated by
the lovely alicia Kraus the Q&A will
stream live on youtube and facebook for
everyone to watch but only daily wire
subscribers can ask me questions to
submit your questions log into daily
wire comm head over to the conversation
livestream to watch that seems intuitive
you should know how to do that type your
question into the chat box and have it
read and answered on the air once again
subscribe to get your questions answered
by little ole me Michael okay again none
of none of that stuff matters the you
get to watch the shows and ask questions
in the mailbag that'll be on Thursday
now that doesn't really this is what
matters this is what matters right here
because what is this vessel worth is
this vessel worth $10,000 it's a worth
$20,000 is it worth $100,000 it's worth
even more than that that's the that is a
leftist tears are worth even more than
$100,000 we offered we said Alexandria
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes please let us
give you $100,000 for your delicious
leftist year she said no they're more
precious they're more valuable than that
think about what and what are we this is
like a hundred bucks for an annual
membership you get this what a steal
that is a discount of orders of
magnitude go to daily we're calm we'll
be right back
all right this is the breaking news
story the breaking news story that the
mainstream media think Donald Trump is
stupid that's what they think he's
stupid you know I know this because I
was checking my news last night my Apple
news on my phone and the big headline
the big story is that Donald Trump he
people have to explain to Donald Trump
what time zones are oh what a fool what
a dolt probably doesn't even know what
time zones are this is the new story and
the the left is running this and they're
saying that people close to Donald Trump
unnamed anonymous sources but don't
worry they're really close to Trump they
say that guy he don't even know what
time zones are you know Donald Trump who
has businesses and property in at least
25 countries around the world has
traveled I don't know everywhere in the
world and who's present political fake
turmoil comes because he regularly
traveled to Russia for his in part
because of his Miss Universe contest you
know you know that the guy who like
famously travels all over the world who
keeps up one of the busiest travel
schedules of anybody he's got meetings
in the morning he's going to rallies in
Michigan at night that kind of guy yeah
he didn't know what time zones are
according to the left and I I'm actually
surprised that the left still is is
going down this path they've been going
down this path for a while they say he's
so stupid what if that here are the
accusations against Trump he doesn't
understand time zones does anybody
really believe that I know the left is
loved to sharing this article the aides
close to Trump anonymous that they say
he doesn't understand time zones does
anybody believe that the evidence by the
way is that he calls foreign leaders at
whatever time he wants to call them but
that doesn't mean he doesn't understand
time zones it means that he cares more
about his time than Emmanuel macron time
it means that he doesn't care yeah oh
I'm sorry that the president of who's
Becky Becky Becky Stan Stan Stan to
quote Herman Cain has to wake up at a
bad hour so that the leader of the free
world can speak to him oh gosh yeah that
means that Donald Trump it just wants to
talk to people and by the way part of
this part of the allegation here is that
he's in constant communication with
world leaders we I thought I thought the
allegation was that he does he
disregards our allies he only wakes up
to insult them and you know
what no he's clearly in constant
communication with them so anyway that's
a pretty stupid one the other one
they're saying he doesn't know what maps
are in this in this article they're
saying he doesn't have to explain to him
what maps are he doesn't know he doesn't
know where countries are on the map and
again I don't want to pick on miss Becca
Stan but you know to again to quote
Herman Cain
if you can't pinpoint who's Becky Becky
Becky Stan Stan Stan that doesn't mean
you're an idiot
right it's you could pick out small some
of the smaller countries in the world on
a map right away you probably couldn't
you know where they are you know that
they exist you know probably even know
some of their geopolitical importance
but that's the other one you don't know
what maps are then names of countries so
we he struggles with the names of
countries he can't pronounce them again
like okay when all of these comments you
know he says they say he doesn't
understand foreign alliances and
rivalries he doesn't know which
countries like one another which are
rival whisper one another which are our
allies or what everyday okay look around
the world right now we are at a time of
Greater peace and prosperity around the
world then basically at any point in
modern presidential history right we've
militarily a mostly defeated Isis we've
avoided major trade Wars we've avoided
major Wars what we've pulled with
de-escalated tensions in Syria we're not
starting random Wars in Libya were not
North Korea seems to be at least at the
negotiating table to denuclearize he's
pretty good on world affairs so if the
argument is he doesn't know anything
about world affairs the evidence seems
to contradict it then the other one this
is another one he only eats fast food
New York Times calls him the fast food
president he only eats fast food keep
barking down that tree that's a great
one to bark to first of all he he owns
many high-end restaurants the other
thing that they said about him was that
he only eats steak every night remember
that was that that was the stupid news
story six months ago
is the eat steak and he burns it and
puts ketchup on it now they're saying he
only it's fast food the other one he
spends the whole day watching TV he's
just watching Fox and Friends all day
when he finishes Fox and Friends in the
morning then he starts watching reruns
of Fox and Friends probably right isn't
that what he does Oh
I mean obviously that isn't true but if
that were true and he's accomplishing
what he's accomplished he's
accomplishing the conservative agenda
the Heritage Foundation agenda at a
faster rate according to
Ronald Reagan did then great keep
watching TV baby keep man out let's get
him a bigger TV maybe he can be even
more successful the other one that he
spends all day golfing again if he's
this effective while golfing keep it up
keep keep cutting buddy he doesn't know
anything about politics or policy this
isn't another canard of the media they
say he's not
they alternately say he's a white
supremacist and that he's not
ideological saying he's got the most
pernicious extreme ideology and he's not
ideological at all doesn't know anything
about politics or policy I'm sick of
this one because I hear it from
conservatives sometimes to this he's not
really conservative you know he's not
really conservative what do you mean
he's not really always he's got the most
conservative record of any president in
modern history yeah but that's an
accident he's not really concerned like
he not yeah I know in the real world
he's conservative but like secretly deep
down really secretly he's not
conservative okay right really deep down
got it then and then the other one is
he's never been good at business you see
the mainstream media constantly talk
about this he's a really terrible at
business I know he succeeded at the
highest levels of obviously politics a
real-estate casinos to television
entertainment right I know he succeeded
at the highest levels of that but really
secretly in the secret world he's not
successful at those yeah I know he has
at least a billion dollars but like
secretly in the secret world he doesn't
have any money
you're you're probably richer than he is
right in the secret world I'm sure
they're all the mainstream media
reporters in the secret fantasy world
that doesn't exist and only exists on
CNN ever and then it's opposite day
right okay but but here the facts remain
and by the way even with all of that all
of these absurd attacks even with
Omarosa no I don't know prostituting
yourself on television her daily of his
daily approval rating is still 50
percent still he's still doing better
than Barack Obama day by day in terms of
personal popularity and Barack Obama was
personally very popular so hahaha before
we go I do want to cover this manna fort
case so the big headline here was that
the manna fort case is wrapping up even
though the defense has not mounted has
not put Paul Manafort on the stand has
not really mounted the defense they're
moving straight to their closing
arguments to put this in perspective
this is basically what the defense's
argument is at this point in the trial
everything that guy just says bull thank
you
that's basically it's basically a very
fitting to have Paul Manafort have a
defense attorney be Joe Pesci so that's
what they're saying they're not going to
put full Manta Ford on the stand they
don't want him to be examined or
cross-examined there they're just making
their closing arguments right now why is
that a few reasons one they might want
to have a show of confidence it could be
it could be a good strategy for opposite
reasons on the one hand they're
confident they're going in and they want
to look confident at least on the other
hand Paul Manafort might be it's arable
witness and we don't want they don't
want the other side to get a piece of
him so either way they're gonna rest it
I think another big aspect is they're
waiting for a presidential pardon
because this is a witch-hunt
I'm not saying Paul Manafort didn't
commit crimes but this this trial has
basically been about a Paul Manafort
that likes really expensive suits that's
the crime he criminally he was
criminally expensive suits and sure he
could be laundered money he did this he
did that he did things that a lot of
lobbyists on both sides of the aisle do
why was he brought under scrutiny why
was he brought under scrutiny by Bob
Muller who was supposed to be
investigating Russian meddling in the
2016 election why does this have nothing
to do with you like why is this it's all
because he worked for Donald Trump that
was his crime he worked for Donald Trump
and so they dug up all this dirt on him
and they're they're prosecuting him now
he's probably just waiting for a
presidential pardon he probably should
get it because this has been an
egregious miscarriage of justice every
step of the way and I say that it
knowing that Paul Manafort probably
committed crimes then I'm sorry I know I
know we're running late what do you want
me to do I got to cover how the deputy
chairman of the DNC might have beaten
ex-girlfriends and nobody's covering
this whatsoever in the media the deputy
chairman of the Democratic National
Committee may have battered women there
are allegations about this and nobody's
covering it here here is the latest that
Karen Monahan the
who is accusing him has now released
some texts here are some texts from from
couple years ago and this happened from
Karen oh this is from Keith Ellison
Karen when can I come to drop your stuff
off what should I expect from Austin her
son he seems pretty upset we talked to
on the show yesterday about why he's
upset he's alleging that keith Ellison
beat his mother then Allison says quote
in a text to this ex-girlfriend I'm
sorry Austin is feeling this way but I
don't know what to do about it it's not
appropriate for me to discuss our
relationship with him so he's just angry
and yet I can't won't offer him any
answers later on Monahan says a lot has
come to light this past year and a half
and the boys have seen some things heard
some things that I've tried to explain
it's been hard on them and shocking it's
taken a lot for me and others to
convince them to allow me to handle
things in my own way in my own time a
lot has happened now from that can we
conclude that keith Ellison beat this
woman no no we can't conclude that they
say that there's a video but that this
hasn't been released nobody's seen it
yet can we conclude that he's beaten
this woman no should we be asking some
questions about it yeah of course the
main look in election years a lot of
stuff comes up even from years past so
I'm always skeptical of these
accusations what I really just want to
point out is the utter hypocrisy from
the mainstream media which found
doctored evidence a doctored yearbook
alleging that Alabama Senate candidate
Roy Moore was prowling for teenage girls
when he was 30 and they crucified him
with this with with what we know is
doctored evidence here we have a woman
saying I was beaten by keith ellison and
they are shutting her up every bit of
reporting says he denied it he's denying
no evidence he's denying the utter
hypocrisy of people who pretend to be
pro-pro me to pro women fighting you
know against the the war on women
whatever also by the way on this
allegation there's another woman who
alleges abuse by keith ellison minnesota
democrat activist amy alexander said
quote i was seduced by the idea of what
I thought he Ellison represented as a
perennial democratic
former labor activists from the north
side of Minneapolis I worked for and
with Allison on a number of issues and
community boards Keith belittled me
about my weight and constantly
criticized my every word in action
he ostracized me from the community on
whose behalf I had worked so hard to
advocate feeling exiled I escaped to New
York for the next five years in May
Keith wanted to try and quiet me so he
came to my home uninvited we had words
his anger kicked in he berated me he
grabbed me and pushed me out of the way
I was terrified I called the police
as he fled he broke my screen door I've
never been so scared so now we have a
second allegation of physical abuse from
the deputy chairman of the DNC I don't
know if I made that clear enough who
heed this guy is the deputy head of the
Democrat Party keith Ellison
a second allegation of physical abuse
and nobody's covering it nobody will
acknowledge it and by the way there
there is a record of this 9-1-1 call
there is a record of this that she did
call this call of 9/11 on Keith Ellison
so there is some evidence here and but
the left won't cover it will they they
won't do it it's funny because Karen
Monahan the first accuser is you know
she did date keith Ellison so that you
do have a certain ideological stripe
when you do that and she did say she's
turning the identity politics on him she
said quote I know who I am I know what I
was going through we aren't anywhere in
society where I wasn't gonna get smeared
as an Iranian as a woman of color who is
an immigrant do you honestly think I'm
gonna get validation from a society
who's been telling me since I was young
that I don't have a voice now of course
American society does not tell Iranian
women that they don't have a voice they
do the opposite of that but I do love
that she's turning the identity politics
on keith ellison that is too delicious
not to save her before we go I know I
know I'm running late too bad I just
want to end on this is America with a
terrific video from Chris Pratt Chris
take it away
thank you guys thank you I'm so thrilled
to be here I have not been a teen for
quite some time I love you too thank you
so much this means a lot to me I know
Brice and I both have so much fun being
part of the Jurassic Park and Jurassic
world franchise I want to thank God I
always do that when I'm up on a big
platform in front of a bunch of young
faces I say I love God that's my thing I
love them and you should too I love God
what a great what a great moment for the
culture we're always complaining about
the culture and here you've got the
biggest movie star in the world Chris
Pratt now this is the second time he's
done this
in one of these big awards shows in
front of a bunch of young kids saying I
love God it reminds me of there was this
great moment when Pope John Paul the
second I'm not comparing Chris Pratt and
the Pope but Pope John Paul the second
during communism came to Poland and you
heard chants you heard shears you heard
we want God we want God this popular
uprising of calling for God because
there's a natural human longing for God
and all of our human longings have
satisfaction when we're hungry we get
food when we're thirsty we have there's
water to drink and the natural human
longing for God does have a satisfaction
in God and it's great to have a guy who
is at the center of popular culture just
just shouting that from the rooftops
that is fantastic so good on you Chris
Pratt this is America how American is
that to just talk about how we love God
well taught well being at the center of
Hollywood movies in exporting culture
really American culture at its best
that's it that's the show sorry I ran
late
we'll be back no we won't be back
tomorrow we're gonna be shown Friday
instead so I'll see you Thursday get
your mailbag questions in in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show I'll see it
Thursday
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy bori senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you